catalytic converters are a really hot
item on thieves list but there is a way
to protect against those thieves madison
kimbrough now explains
it was here in this northwest valley
shopping area that halen had his
catalytic converter stolen in broad
daylight and now with the fear of it
happening again he's considering buying
the parts to protect it but is it worth
it i'm still doing research into some
more options right now if they can cut
it out i feel like they could just cut
through the wire or whatever pretty
easily having just moved to the area
haylin is now hesitant to park his car
in public places in fear of this
happening again he took his car to best
muffler shop off fremont street for
repair manager dan dimelo says the
number of clients he sees daily for cat
thefts is soaring and says while there
are parts you can get for protection
it's not one size fits all a lot of the
times custom is really the best way if
it really is an issue where the vehicle
is targeted then i would typically
myself take a look at it see what would
work or if it even is worth the time
demelo says the best protection he has
seen are called plates the ones i've
seen best are more like plates it's
pretty much a cover for the whole
underside of where they're trying to
steal something takes too long to get
through it it's too much of a hassle
they're just going to go to the next car
and as for the amount of money it takes
to buy these protective parts it can set
you back a couple hundred dollars at
least but there's no guarantee that with
the right tools this won't happen again
reporting from farm in durango madison
kimbrough live local now